hello everyone Karen warden with film
courage the radio show we're outside the
studio with Sean Hackett of homecoming
had a wonderful interview it went by
much too quickly there were a lot of
questions that we didn't get to and
we've just been enjoying some wonderful
bagels like he brought for us and he
he's made a point to us to make sure to
always feed the crew and make the crew
happy so the crew is very happy here at
film courage a lot of things we didn't
get to that we want to talk about one of
which was um you know a sense of
community and indie films I think to in
LA there doesn't really seem to be that
I mean it's a very competitive town
understandably and it's kind of hard to
it's just hard we would collaborate
whereas I'm sure smaller towns there's
more of a collaboration talk about what
you've seen in terms of indie film and a
community and how it could be
strengthened here yeah definitely I
think one of my pet peeves in Los
Angeles was working on a film set and
constantly looking at my watch when I
was like eight o'clock or traffic hour
or wondering what dinner would be and
there's something kind of sad about
green trina job like an entire film like
a nine-to-five job where you go home and
you don't really connect with the crew
anymore they're not you know you go home
and you play on the computer you do
something and then you go back and what
I love about filmmaking this is almost
green like a summer camp experience for
everyone and in that way you know you go
into the middle of nowhere and see you
versus the world and you're there to
have that backyard experience that you
always
of being an entity on a film set and
becoming best friends almost family
members we call our foam style family
style filmmaking not just because we
have a lot of family members who work
together but because we act like a
family Vito own meals together and and
and I mean that that's the stuff that
shows even on screen because like
between bria places sell and Tom and
myself and and all the other cast we
became really close and and we kind of
got that friendship on screen because we
had in real life which which is
essential I think there's there's
nothing better than that having
relationships with people and some of
the best movies to come out lots of 15
years they weren't shot him and all I
they were shot in raw small towns or or
you know growing communities like
Seattle or Austin or New Orleans and
people in those towns get so excited
about you shooting a movie I mean it I'm
from the Midwest if someone came to my
house and said we won't shoot a movie
there they would be elated you know that
it would be the coolest sentence ever
happened and that's read that they've
lived on well my best friend's is Mike
Glaser who's spending mothers day with
his mom and I said that we shot them out
on the radio show but we didn't um but
but Mike's the locations manager and
he's so excited to maybe go work in
Kansas City or New Orleans or or
Nashville or somewhere like that because
he gets to interact with real people who
really want to be part of something
that's big it's an art project but a
whole community gets involved well you
talked about how the three of you had
this off-screen chemistry and it
definitely showed in the film and one of
my questions for you to that we didn't
get to was how are you able to make the
audience care about your characters
because you really did care about them
where sometimes it's just they're so
one-dimensional and some films that
just no connection yeah how are you able
to do that um I think a lot of it was
kind of through development um making
sure that that characters went through
ranges of emotions that were real
aesthetically like um you know putting
the men's situations that we can kind of
relate to I there's a person who was
just reviewing a movie caterer blonde
deserved manage your rights for a board
in the wailin and she says that movies
are starting to come apart
compartmentalize women so women are
either you know the sassy fun friend or
the you know like uptight a you know
friend who doesn't want to have fun and
you just watch them go against each
other and I think when it comes down to
people and their group of friends it's
not so much like old style sitcom you
know that they're real emotions and real
ranges of of how you you react to your
friend's son and I think with with bria
what we want to do especially with her
was just create a strong character and
forgive that she's in the military for a
little bit and entry free her missing
home like the character will be missing
home not like let's make your typical
smolder you know and once let's have her
have some fears that are maybe petty but
they're cute now simplicity is the magic
sometimes and not having Quentin
Tarantino dialogue but just real
emotions and what you said to is you
know they felt real a lot of the just
came from making sure the dialogue was
always fresh between us and that we were
creating our own dialogue I I don't try
to make improv scenes because it's the
fun new thing to do I like it because
you can get a great line from a person
that resonates with you because it's
coming from their soul and that's that's
a special effect that movies have and
then and in world as the soul and that's
all I have the budget to show
and you mentioned to another interview
that you did then there was one scene
where you all had to be mad at each
other yeah and so you spent a very very
long day I guess there were a lot of
tanks in this really angered state so
talk about how that was and then you're
still all friends how did you keep from
emotions from crossing the line and that
sense I think it really came down to me
going into like a small quiet area with
the afters and telling them why we were
doing the same you know it's not so much
me versus you even though a lot of
improv came out especially between well
between all three of us you know and and
we were saying things that maybe were
more personal than what did I allow even
had down but why we had this
conversation because I think to me this
film is as maybe you know it's all about
friendship and it's about going back
home to those friends and growing as a
coming-of-age door in a really odd way
which are my favorite stories of all
time and I think you know when we came
down to it that those hard seems they
were exhausting but we all kind of left
the building knowing that we had to give
our best for that to work because fights
and movies best fights or yelling fights
or anything can be very as like as that
would be challenged like they can be
kind of artificial um and can kind of
sunlight I'm very bad at you right now
and this is why you know and and and
doing Al Pacino impressions between the
three of you so we try to we try to make
it more realistic and make it as awkward
as watching three people have a fight
that are very close between
and then lastly your thoughts on day and
eating a film yeah yeah um you know I I
really I like from festivals a lot and I
think that that's that's a way to not
just like reach out to an audience but
find that kid who's in high school right
now and then maybe you want to make a
short film and just like showing them
that my phone was made for under a
hundred thousand dollars and it was it
looks really good it looks better than
that and it's it's it's putting that
fear because I'm from the Midwest and we
put so much fear into you can't do it
and and and and hopefully inspiring
people I mean I think you know the first
film that you make it's a be personal
and then kind of your first audience
it's just going to be other filmmakers
you know and getting to know those other
phone makers um you know I think we're
part of a really really awesome
generation right now we're we're I'm not
trying to be competitive I just I want
us to all succeed you know and grow
together you know I want to be part of
this this rush and so that's you know
people call the Obama generation you
know where we're not saying no to new
ideas and creativity and I hope I can
help some people out and i hope i can
also you know total gets store in that
process and film
Oh